Saludos Valentina desde esta conferencia
internacional sobre el proceso político
de Venezuela estamos en el Palacio de
San Carlos en el centro de Bogotá en la
capital de Colombia y justo detrás de mí
están ahora reunidas las 20 delegaciones
internacionales que han acudido a esta
Cumbre Gustavo Petro como bien has dicho
inauguró esta conferencia hizo un repaso
histórico y hasta el presente y dijo que
hay que avanzar hacia la reconstrucción
democrática de la región también se
refirió concretamente a Venezuela al que
ha instado a gobierno de Nicolás maduro
a regresar al sistema interamericano de
Derechos Humanos el cual abandonó Hugo
Chávez en 2012 también como ha dicho en
este fragmento de audio que escuchábamos
ha dicho que la región debe ser un
espacio libre de sanciones y debe ser un
espacio de libertades se espera que la
Cumbre termine a las 5 de la tarde con
una declaración del canciller de
Colombia Álvaro Leyva y se nos han
comentado desde cancillería que las
reuniones bilaterales entre gobiernos
entre estas delegaciones se produjeron
justo antes de las declaraciones de
Gustavo Petro Luis que otros detalles se
conocen de este episodio previo ocurrido
con Juan guaidó
esta Cumbre está siendo opacada por Juan
guaidó y es que el líder sorprendió a
todos Ayer por la mañana entrando a pie
por una de las trochas él declaró que
como millones de venezolanos él
pretendía estar Este martes liderando
las manifestaciones de la diáspora
también reunirse con unas delegaciones
internacionales pero ya durante todo el
lunes la cancillería denunció que Juan
guaidó había ingresado de forma
irregular y en horas de la tarde lo
llevaron el aeropuerto para salir a
Estados Unidos dicen que no es una
deportación tampoco una expulsión al
llegar Juan guaidó a Estados Unidos dijo
que temía por la integridad de su
familia en Venezuela y también dijo que
esto era un acto más de la expansión de
la dictadura de Venezuela hacia Colombia
por su parte le respondió el presidente
de Colombia Gustavo Petro dijo que esta
salida de Juan guaidó a Estados Unidos
ya estaba acordada con Estados Unidos y
le dijo que bien podía haber pedido
haber entrado con el pasaporte y haber
pedido asilo político en Colombia